so you're a rich parent who wants the
best education for your kids you want no
you need your kid to get into the most
prestigious university possible not just
for the education but for the pedigree
the prestige the status because the
right pedigree does make life
ridiculously easier pedigree just means
you come from the right family you have
the right degree from the right
prestigious university and this is one
of the rare cases where a degree
actually matters you also need everyone
to know that your family is superior to
theirs in every way possible because
so you have to do everything in your
power to get your kid into an elite
college like yale or stanford or else
but there's just one problem your kids
are rich kids they were born into wealth
so unless you were a very good parent
and i mean an extremely good parent they
don't have the same drive as you they
didn't have to work for what they have
no you forever ruined their motivation
in life so they probably don't have the
best grades they probably don't excel in
any extracurricular activities meaning
they're screwed because these elite
universities have extremely high
standards when it comes to who they let
in
most of america's top universities have
acceptance rates somewhere between just
five to ten percent these colleges
aren't looking for average students from
rich families they're looking for the
most book smart minds in the country if
your kid's sat score isn't in the 1500
range don't even bother trying so this
makes getting your kid into one of these
elite universities with an official
application almost impossible you can
already hear people whispering behind
your back from a mile away this
successful guy couldn't even get his kid
into an elite college what a loser so an
official application is out of the
question but fear not because we have a
solution money money money
see in this world money does buy you
shortcuts if you think that's unfair get
rich for yourself so you can buy these
shortcuts too now the obvious route
you're probably thinking about is hey
i'll just make a giant donation to the
school i'll donate like a library or
something slap my name on the building
and then they'll have to let in my kid
right well not quite see large donations
like this are not only expensive we're
talking about millions of dollars but
it's also a little bit too obvious a
little too out in the open one day
there's a new research facility where
your last name on it and the next day
your degenerate kid is admitted it just
doesn't look good it's too brazen and
most importantly unless you've got some
deep connections with the heads of the
school even that large of a donation is
not guaranteed to get your kid in
we need more certainty we need something
where i bribe you with x amount of
dollars and my kid is guaranteed into
the school well that's where our guy
rick singer comes in william rick singer
was a california college admissions
consultant who had a miraculous 100
success rates he could get any loser
into the school of their dreams for a
price though but that price was actually
a ridiculous bargain compared to
donating a whole new building to a
school and the best part it was
guaranteed to work
by going to rick you don't have to worry
about an official application or making
an insane 40 million donation you
wouldn't have sleepless nights wondering
if your kid will get in you would just
pay the consultation fee and your kid
was as good as accepted
it was a game changer but when the fbi
found out it also turned out to be the
biggest college emissions scandal in us
history
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to
stay dangerous and this is operation
varsity blues
[Music]
do you like free stuff well you can get
up to 12 free stocks yes up to 12 free
stocks value up to 30 600 when you sign
up for weeble with the link below and
deposit any amounts yes you can
literally deposit as little as one
dollar after opening an account and
you'll still get the free stocks so you
might as well pause the video and click
the link below to claim it now the first
two shares you get when you open your
account would be value up to three
hundred dollars each and the next four
to ten shares you get when you deposit
any amount into your account would be
valued up to three thousand dollars each
and yes once the stocks have settled in
your accounts you can sell them use that
money to buy other stocks or even
withdraw the money the only catch is
that this promotion is not gonna last
forever so you're gonna want to do this
as soon as possible if you're not aware
weeble is a really great commission free
stock trading app that was ranked the
best investment app in 2021 by benzynga
and it has a 4.5 star rating from
nerdwallet so what are you waiting for
get your free stocks right now by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to weeble for sponsoring
this video
rick's services were very affordable all
it cost to get average or even below
average kids into some of the best
schools in the country was a small
donation of 250 to 400 000
officially these donations went to the
singers foundation to quote unlock the
door to academic social personal and
career success end quote for the
underprivileged youth but we both know
different see rick found a loophole in
the admission system going through the
regular admissions process as a student
is tough but if you were an incredible
athlete and you got recruited as an
athlete admissions could care less about
your academic performance they just want
another star athlete at their university
to make their school look better so if
you can get your kid recruited as an
athlete to the school they were as good
as admitted now you may be thinking but
my kid isn't a pro athlete my kid has
never played a sport in their life
calm down calm down your degenerate kid
can be as uncoordinated as they want you
just let rick work his magic
once you pay rick his donation rick
would then cut a deal with a coach at
the school you're after recruit this
degenerate rich kid as your athlete and
you get money
once the coach accepts the lucrative
deal which they always do now it's time
to make your kid look like an elite
athlete on paper this is where the
beauty of photoshop comes in
a client once asked rick singer which
sport would be best for his twin
daughters singer told him that it would
make sense to turn them into sailors
since they lived on a cape
have they ever sailed before probably
not did they know anything about sailing
highly unlikely but all rick and his
associates had to do was fake a few
pictures of these rich kids playing the
sport they were being recruited for and
boom we have a pro-sailing athletes once
they had a professional profile the
coach would present the athlete as their
new top recruit to the admissions
committee the admissions committee
obviously trusts whoever this
prestigious coach brings to them so just
like that these kids made it into the
college of their dreams
it was that simple
suddenly these elite colleges had
basketball players who were 5'5 water
polo players who didn't seem to like
swimming and soccer players who couldn't
score a goal to save their lives but
none of that mattered once they got
accepted they simply didn't show up for
practice
but what if rick didn't know a coach at
the university you want to get your kid
into well that's where his network of
test administrators came in handy if
your kid didn't have great sat or act
scores singer would arrange for a
private exam under the watchful eyes of
a test administrator who had already
gotten their bribe of ten thousand
dollars
rick got two hundred fifty thousand to
four hundred thousand dollars from the
parents and all he had to pay was a
measly ten thousand dollars to the test
administrator it was a very high margin
product
during the exam your kid would write the
answers to questions on a separate sheet
of paper once they answered everything
to the best of their knowledge they
would leave thinking they had taken a
real exam but that couldn't be further
from the truth in reality once your kid
was out of the building the test
administrator would take the exam
themselves carefully working on all of
your kids original answers until they
reached the exact score you had asked
for suddenly these below average kids
had sat scores in the 1500 range and a
ct scores in the mid 30s and since they
were now some of the smartest minds in
the country the doors to america's top
colleges were wide open it was the
perfect scheme and sure some of the
parents felt guilty and wanted to
confess everything to their kid but rick
urged them not to he wanted these kids
to believe that it was all legit and he
especially didn't want them telling more
people about his little operation
unfortunately for rick no matter how
hard he tried to keep his money-making
scheme a secret his house of cards
finally began to collapse in 2018
[Music]
in april 2018 a businessman from los
angeles was arrested by the fbi the
charge securities fraud at first it
seemed like a standard fraud case
nothing too spectacular but just like
most men who suddenly faced jail time
the businessman was desperate to make
any sort of deal to save his own skin
so he offered the fed some information
they didn't see coming
according to him rudy meredith the yale
women's soccer coach had asked him if he
wanted to get his daughter into yale for
450 000
to the fbi this sounded a lot like
bribery so the feds began to dig a
little deeper
luckily for the fbi scammers and
millionaires don't have the same code of
silence like the mafia and when they're
given the chance to save their own skin
they will spill all the beans
when the fbi brought rudy the soccer
coach into the interrogation room he
immediately spilled the beans about the
entire admissions operation and its
criminal mastermind rick singer
and just like that the fbi had pretty
much been handed the guy at the top of
it all but that wasn't enough the fbi
knew rick's scheme was something far
bigger than just a couple of bribes here
and there
this was a huge scandal involving some
of the most elite colleges in america
and some of the country's wealthiest
families
so the fbi wasn't happy with just taking
down the ringleader
they wanted the names of everyone
the coaches the test administrators the
parents everyone who had a hand in the
scheme
so they offered singer a deal he would
get the chance for a reduced sentence if
he would wear a wire while he called his
clients
like the opportunist he was he
immediately agreed
now working for the fbi rick singer
began calling all his wealthy clients
pretending to check up on their kids or
update them on his plans
and thanks to his manipulative skills
rick had no problem squeezing his
clients out of as many incriminating
details as possible all while the fbi
was secretly listening in
and one by one all these wealthy
families were eventually outed
uncovering the biggest college
admissions scandal in u.s history
[Music]
from 2011 to 2018 about 50 families paid
singer a total of 25 million dollars to
get their kids into elite colleges like
stanford yale georgetown or usc
actresses ceos venture capitalists and
even high-profile lawyers they all use
their wealth to buy their kids a
shortcut
one la businessman had paid four hundred
thousand dollars to get his son into
georgetown as a fake tennis recruit
a real estate tycoon from the bay area
paid six hundred thousand dollars to get
his two daughters into ucla and usc
even actress laurie lachlan who was in
the sitcom full house paid hundred
thousand dollars to get their two
daughters recruited to usc through the
women's rowing team
olivia jade their online influencer
daughter had quite an impressive resume
it describes her as highly talented and
successful in both women's and men's
boats according to her resume she even
won a gold medal in 2016.
on paper she looked like a rising star
in the rowing world ambitious focused
and talented who wouldn't want someone
like that in their university but none
of this was true
neither of the sisters had ever
participated in the sport instead one of
the usc coaches had crafted the fake
document and it was enough to get olivia
into usc without raising any suspicion
and the best part since the six figure
payments to rick singer were labeled as
donations the parents involved also
received a nice little tax write-off at
the end of the year this enabled the
parents to not only mask the true nature
of the payment but also take the tax
write-off at the end of the year
no one had ever expected they would be
caught
after all paying to get your kid into
university couldn't be that big of a
deal right everyone does it
unfortunately for them the fbi didn't
see it that way and thanks to all the
wiretap calls most parents had no choice
but to plead guilty
in the end most of them had to pay
five-figure fines and some even served a
few weeks to a few months in prison and
rick singer he faces a maximum of 65
years in prison as of right now he's
still a free man waiting to be sentenced
even though they had to pay some hefty
fines and serve some jail time it looks
like the wealthy elite have pretty much
gotten away with their scheme and the
college admission scandal wasn't even
the most shocking operation involving
the wealthy elite that got uncovered in
recent years there's another case where
the elite got away with something much
more despicable every gepstein
epstein helped build a ponzi scheme and
then used that money to snake his way
into the most powerful circles in the
world
eventually setting up an operation where
he would bring powerful people to his
properties to party with underage girls
and record everything via secret hidden
cameras
and every time he got in trouble with
the law the same pattern would play out
he would be magically let free
until one day his secret protectors the
people keeping him safe from jail turned
their back on him and we all know what
happened then
but talking about all the details of
epstein's operation and his suspicious
death would definitely get demonetized
on youtube
which is why we've released a private
documentary on the man who didn't kill
himself
going over all the sick details
available only to members of this
channel and so far people have been
loving the documentary
all you have to do to get access to the
video on every jepsteen and all the
other documentary length videos that are
too controversial too dark too risky to
post publicly is to click the join
button below
once you sign up you'll also get
exclusive access to documentaries on cia
black sites mk ultra the bin laden
papers and many more these are the
things they should be teaching you in
university about how the world works but
unlike university you get all of this
for just five dollars a month
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there is no refund
so scroll down and hit that join button
below now
did you know that college admissions
were this corrupt i kind of just assumed
they were so i really wanted to make
this video and you know how we were
never taught how to move up in this
world in school well that is the purpose
of this channel we make documentaries on
money power war and crime so that you
can learn all the stuff they were too
afraid to tell you in school in the most
entertaining manner possible so if that
interests you click that subscribe
button below but that's going to wrap it
up thank you so much for being part of
the watch the n club stay dangerous and
i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you